Alice: 查小红书的时候
Alice: When I was checking Xiaohongshu
Alice: 他给我推了一些奇怪的内容
Alice: It recommended some weird stuff to me
Alice: 我还点进去看了
Alice: And I even clicked in to look
Alice: 我觉得很社死怎么办
Alice: I felt so socially awkward, what should I do
Alice: 还录下来了
Alice: And I recorded it
Alice: 哈哈哈无所谓吧
Alice: Hahaha, whatever
Lucia: 应该他们会处理吧
Lucia: They should handle it, right?
Alice: 无所谓喽
Alice: It’s whatever
Lucia: 没事我觉得我们打开社交软件时候
Lucia: It’s fine, I think when we open social media
Lucia: 肯定会出现各种
Lucia: All sorts of things will pop up
Alice: 巨尴尬无比的东西哈哈哈
Alice: Super awkward stuff, hahaha
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let’s go
Lucia: 拿一下礼物走吧
Lucia: Let’s grab the gifts and go
Shure:  还有交换礼物的活动是吗
Shure: Is there a gift exchange event too?
Shure:  是要带着礼物上去吗
Shure: Do we have to bring the gifts up?
Tasha: 啊先不用了  啊好
Tasha: Ah, not yet. Ah, okay.
Katrina:  品尝饮料
Katrina: Tasting drinks
Shure:  哎呦完了
Shure: Oh no
Shure:  我刚喝完咖啡
Shure: I just finished my coffee
Shure:  喝不出来
Shure: I can’t taste anything
Katrina:  我也是
Katrina: Me too
Shure:  一会漱一下口吧
Shure: Let’s rinse our mouths later
Lucia: 品尝饮料
Lucia: Tasting drinks
Lucia: 饮料好像已经快被我们喝光了
Lucia: Looks like we’ve almost finished the drinks
Lucia: 我记得
Lucia: I remember
Tasha: 还有存货
Tasha: There’s more stock
Katrina:  天呐感觉有那个魔鬼料理
Katrina: Oh my, it feels like there’s some devilish food
Alice: 呃那那我等你吧
Alice: Uh, then I’ll wait for you
Tasha: 你先上去看看，看看他们干啥
Alice: 哦行
Alice: 那要特别急的话我就下来叫你
Lucia: 对哦就是很急
Lucia: Yeah, it’s really urgent
Alice: 不过应该也不会很急
Alice: 你上去了宝
Katrina:  我靠他居然能敷上去
Katrina: Wow, he actually put it on
Katrina:  哇哈哈有点急
Katrina: Wow haha, it’s a bit urgent
Alice: 这个让我的花花面对着你
Alice: I’ll have my flower face you
Tasha: 然后从每个杯子里尝出不同的水
Tasha: And then taste different water from each cup
Alice: 好不要紧张
Tasha: 还有几分钟就上去
Alice: 我要把我花花对着你
Alice: 走了
Alice: 恩，好的
Alice: 这是什么
Alice: What is this?
Alice: 这是
Alice: This is
Alice: 苏打水跟什么
Alice: Soda water with what?
Shure:  水水水水水水水
Shure: Water, water, water, water, water, water
Alice: 这个不是有气泡吗
Alice: Isn't this carbonated?
Shure:  啊只有一杯是那个元气森林
Shure: Ah, only one cup is from Genki Forest.
Shure:  其他都是普通的
Shure: The rest are just regular ones.
Alice: 这是要干嘛
Alice: What's this for?
Lucia: 这是
Lucia: This is...
Shure:  品鉴
Shure: A tasting.
Lucia: 品鉴不同的水
Lucia: Tasting different waters.
Jake: 好请大家请坐
Jake: Okay, everyone, please take a seat.
Jake: 各就各位
Jake: Get ready.
Jake: 齐了吗没齐
Jake: Are we all set? Not yet?
Jake: 大家挑一个位置吧
Jake: Everyone, pick a spot.
Jake: 座位也不太重要
Jake: The seating doesn't really matter.
Jake: 薇薇干嘛去了
Jake: Where did Tasha go?
Shure:  薇薇有点急事
Shure: Tasha had something urgent.
Jake: 哦莫急莫急
Jake: Oh, no rush, no rush.
Alice: 这个这个
Alice: This one, this one...
Alice: 放这吧放那边吧
Alice: Put it here, or over there.
Tasha: 你要不坐那啊  你坐那C位
Tasha: Why don't you sit there? You can take the center seat.
Shure:  尝试一下king
Shure: Try it, King.
Alice: 哪个要喝了吗
Alice: Which one are we drinking first?
Jake: 等等一下吧
Jake: Let's wait a bit.
Jake: 就是薇薇她是出不来是吧
Jake: So Tasha isn't coming out, right?
Alice: 呃几分钟就好了
Alice: Uh, just a few minutes.
Jake: 好那等等她吧
Jake: Okay, let's wait for her.
Alice: 你不会要喝哪哪个的味道吧
Alice: You don't want to taste all of them, do you?
Shure:  是的yes
Shure: Yes, I do.
Shure:  你觉得你能尝出来吗
Shure: Do you think you can tell the difference?
Katrina:  我从来没有留意过
Katrina: I've never really paid attention to it.
Katrina:  就是不同矿泉水的味道
Katrina: Like, the taste of different mineral waters.
Shure:  你不会就忠于买哪个牌子吗
Shure: Don't you stick to a certain brand?
Katrina:  不会啊随便买
Katrina: No, I just buy whatever.
Katrina:  不是哪个价格低就买哪个
Katrina: Usually whichever is cheaper.
Shure:  我就不爱喝农夫山泉
Shure: I just don't like Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  其他都可以
Shure: Anything else is fine.
Shure:  所以农夫山泉一定能尝
Shure: So I can definitely recognize Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  然后最爱喝的是怡宝啊
Shure: My favorite is Yibao.
Alice: 对怡宝甜
Alice: Yeah, Yibao is sweet.
Shure:  对怡宝是甜
Shure: Yeah, Yibao is sweet.
Shure:  农夫山泉根本不甜
Shure: Nongfu Spring isn't sweet at all.
Shure:  好像怡宝是偏一点酸性
Shure: It seems like Yibao is a bit acidic.
Shure:  说是不是那么健康
Shure: Saying it's not that healthy.
Katrina:  哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Shure:  怡宝  就是它PH值
Shure: Yibao, its pH level.
Katrina:  哪个水最好来着
Katrina: Which water is the best?
Shure:  娃哈哈哦
Shure: Wahaha.
Alice: 娃哈哈最啥实
Alice: Wahaha is the most what?
Shure:  实验用水都是
Shure: It's used for experiments.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 好这个
Jake: Okay, this one.
Jake: 怎么说呢
Jake: How should I say this...
Jake: 先不要说话
Jake: Don't talk first.
Jake: 然后写答案
Jake: Then write your answers.
Jake: 好可以开始
Jake: Alright, you can start.
Alice:写哪？
Jake: 不要交流
Jake: No talking.
Jake: 对 不要
Jake: Yes, don't.
Jake: 写写写充电宝
Jake: Write, write, write power bank.
Shure:  写充电宝
Shure: Write power bank.
Jake: 上来发充电宝
Jake: Come up and give out power banks.
Shure:  我的充电宝真的都当手卡用
Shure: My power bank is really used as a hand card.
Alice: 只有一根笔吧
Jake: 对一支笔
Jake: Yes, one pen.
Jake: 或者哈哈
Jake: Or haha.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 我记得楼下有便签啊哎
Lucia: I remember there are sticky notes downstairs, hey.
Jake: 对用便签也可以
Jake: Yes, you can use sticky notes.
Jake: 但是笔就这么一点
Jake: But there are so few pens.
Jake: 我有笔我有笔
Jake: I have a pen, I have a pen.
Alice: 现在是不是可以开始尝了
Alice: Can we start tasting now?
Alice: 吧
Alice: Right?
Jake: 什么什么
Jake: What, what?
Alice: 可以开始喝了吧
Alice: Can we start drinking now?
Jake: 可以上了
Jake: You can start.
Tasha: 一直连不上啊
Shure:  没开机吧
Shure: Maybe it's not turned on?
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake: 很有可能
Jake: Very likely.
Shure:  你别别这么夸
Shure: Don't praise me like that.
Shure:  哈哈哈我没法接了哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, I can't respond to that, hahaha.
Lucia: 应该说不愧是我
Lucia: You should say "as expected of me."
Shure:  这怎么还甜呢
Shure: How is this even sweet?
Shure:  不是他哎呀
Shure: It's not him, oh gosh
Jake: 不准说话啊
Jake: No talking!
Jake: 可以就是把握尺度啊
Jake: Just keep it within limits
Jake: 就是保证你们答案不一样
Jake: Make sure your answers are different
Shure:  嗯这个尝试
Shure: Hmm, give this a try
Alice: 喝完咖啡喝啥都一个味
Alice: 怎么办
Lucia: 完了
Lucia: It's over
Shure:  有这个应该提前通知我们一下
Shure: You should have informed us beforehand
Jake: 咖啡还是得喝的
Jake: We still need to drink the coffee
Jake: 对吧好
Jake: Right, okay
Tasha: 这瓶是矿泉水
Tasha: This bottle is mineral water
Jake: 这应该是食堂里
Jake: This should be from the canteen
Jake: 哦你找到了一些
Jake: Oh, you found some
Lucia: 好多矿泉水
Lucia: So much mineral water
Jake: 哈哈好搞笑
Jake: Haha, so funny
Tasha: 这个是矿泉水
Tasha: This is mineral water
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 哈哈矿泉水
Jake: Haha, mineral water
Jake: 对是谢彬主带来的
Jake: Yeah, it was brought by Xie Bin
Tasha: 你不用喝都知道
Tasha: You can tell without even drinking it
Jake: 好酷这个
Jake: This is so cool
Jake: 我我们找到一些环保的方案哈哈哈
Jake: We found some environmental solutions, haha
Lucia: 废物利用
Lucia: Waste utilization
Jake: 太环保了
Jake: So eco-friendly
Tasha: 这个餐巾纸我想要一张
Tasha: I want a piece of this napkin
Tasha: 这倒的漏出来了水
Jake:好，不好意思
Jake: 不差了不差了
Jake: It's okay, it's okay
Jake: 然后这边有好几支笔
Jake: And there are several pens here
Lucia: 我是不是得用这种啊
Lucia: Am I supposed to use this one?
Lucia: 你也是可以
Lucia: You can use it too
Jake: 你们就换着用
Jake: Just switch around
Jake: 或者有没有纸
Jake: Or is there any paper?
Lucia: 这样我就可以用
Lucia: Then I can use it
Tasha: 这这个是怎么怎么呢
Tasha: How does this work?
Tasha: 怎么写编号呢
Tasha: How do you write the numbers?
Tasha: 哦哦123456
Tasha: Oh, 123456
Jake: 对哦嗯
Jake: Yes, right
Jake: 我我我我我觉得这个有点小
Jake: I think this is a bit small
Lucia: 他写不下啊
Lucia: It can't fit everything
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Lucia: 底下还有这种黑纸盒吗
Lucia: Is there this kind of black paper box underneath?
Lucia: 730以后再喝别的来
Lucia: Drink something else after 7:30.
Jake: 这样
Jake: Like this.
Lucia: Oh Jesus
Lucia: Oh Jesus.
Katrina:  随便写吧
Katrina: Just write whatever.
Shure:  你肯定先避开下一个
Shure: You definitely avoid the next one.
Tasha: 我觉得这应该写ABCDE
Tasha: I think this should be written as ABCDE.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 其实你们有些人带着充电宝对吧
Jake: Actually, some of you have power banks, right?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 你自己
Jake: You yourself...
Lucia: 哎这样可以少写好些字对
Lucia: Hey, this way we can write fewer words, right?
Alice:坏了，一个味
Shure:  这次都不用尝就看出来了啊
Shure: This time we don't even need to taste it to figure it out.
Katrina:  转一个弯
Katrina: Turn a corner.
Katrina:  最纯净哦
Katrina: The purest, oh.
Shure:  写写写编号对
Shure: Write, write, write the number.
Lucia: 有的水喝过来没记住那个味怎么办
Lucia: What if I can't remember the taste after drinking the water?
Tasha: 尝不出来啊
Tasha: Can't tell the difference.
Jake: 多尝几次
Jake: Taste it more.
Jake: 哈哈多尝几次
Jake: Haha, taste it more.
Lucia: 喝完了快
Lucia: Drink it quickly.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 这么这么渴吗
Jake: Are you that thirsty?
Alice: 不是尝尝尝尝
Alice: No, just taste, taste, taste.
Lucia: 刚好补充水分
Lucia: Just replenishing water.
Katrina:  交卷
Katrina: Hand in the paper.
Katrina:  嗯没有笔吗
Katrina: Hmm, no pen?
Shure:  3都长出来了
Shure: Number 3 has grown out already.
Katrina:  整的现在
Katrina: Do it now.
Jake: 尝出来了
Jake: Figured it out.
Katrina:  鉴酒似的
Katrina: Like wine tasting.
Lucia: 嗯可以可以
Lucia: Hmm, okay, okay.
Lucia: 能写就行
Lucia: As long as you can write.
Jake: a b c d f
Jake: a, b, c, d, f.
Jake: 我也想尝尝
Jake: I also want to taste.
Jake: 一会再尝
Jake: Taste it later.
Jake: 我们一会再尝尝
Jake: We'll taste it later.
Shure:  摸温度哈哈哈好聪明
Shure: Feeling the temperature, haha, so smart.
Tasha: 有一瓶好冰啊
Tasha: One bottle is really cold.
Jake: 啊哦真的
Jake: Oh really?
Alice: 在哪啊不是在哪洗
Alice: Where is it? Isn't it supposed to be here?
Shure:  我估计应该最冰的是他
Shure: I guess the coldest one should be him.
Shure:  因为他最大
Shure: Because he's the biggest.
Shure:  有没有可能
Shure: Is that possible?
Tasha: 有一瓶好冰啊
Tasha: There's one bottle that's super cold.
Alice: 哎答案写在哪啊
Alice: Hey, where's the answer written?
Katrina:  掰一下给你
Katrina: Let me break it down for you.
Alice: 哦可以可以
Alice: Oh, okay, okay.
Alice: 不过我按我的顺序跟他对一下
Alice: But let me match it with my order.
Alice: 好这样写
Alice: 这样可以
Alice: This works.
Alice: 这是啥呀  甲
Alice: What's this? A?
Katrina:  拿这写也行
Katrina: You can write with this too.
Shure:  f
Shure: F
Alice:好的
Shure:  这是f的话题
Shure: This is an F topic.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Right?
Jake: 我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 我乱写
Jake: I'm just writing randomly.
Tasha: 有白板笔吗
Tasha: Do we have a whiteboard marker?
Jake: 样题
Jake: Sample question.
Shure:  我绝对不能把我的一包选错
Shure: I definitely can't choose the wrong packet.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina:  拭目以待
Katrina: Let's wait and see.
Lucia: 能从这个圆这瓶里再倒出来喝吗
Lucia: Can we pour it out from this round bottle and drink it?
Shure:  疯了
Shure: Crazy.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No,
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Lucia: 比较一下吗
Lucia: Just comparing.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Shure:  没有空杯子
Shure: No empty cups.
Lucia: 喝完某一个就好了
Lucia: Just finish one of them.
Jake: 我们有几位已经整出来了吗感觉
Jake: Do we have a few people who already figured it out?
Jake: 已经交卷了
Jake: They've handed it in?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 这么牛逼
Jake: So impressive.
Katrina:  主要是我从来
Katrina: Mainly because I never...
Jake: 我看一看建浩老师
Jake: Let me take a look at Mr. Jianhao's answers.
Jake: 来看你的答案
Jake: Let's see your answers.
Katrina:  哈哈哈鹅
Katrina: Hahaha goose.
Shure:  猜
Shure: Guess.
Katrina:  主要是全不会
Katrina: Mainly, I don't know anything.
Katrina:  就跟那种完全没学过一样
Katrina: It's like I haven't studied at all.
Katrina:  然后哈哈哈
Katrina: And then hahaha
Jake: 就可以替身交卷
Jake: You can just have a stand-in submit it.
Shure:  都选c吧
Shure: Just choose C for everything.
Shure:  那不就
Shure: Won't that...
Katrina:  对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  但是都写怡宝
Katrina: But write "Yibao" for everything.
Alice:我也写完了
Katrina:  总有一个对的
Katrina: One of them has to be correct.
Lucia: 好有道理
Lucia: That makes so much sense.
Katrina:  矿泉水
Katrina: Mineral water.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 我打算都写怡宝
Lucia: I'm planning to write "Yibao" for everything.
Jake: 哈哈我看看你的怡宝对不对
Jake: Haha, I'll check if your "Yibao" is correct.
Shure:  是不是对的
Shure: Is it correct?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Shure:  你看监考是回避我的
Shure: Look, the invigilator is avoiding me.
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake: 那我还能怎么说呢
Jake: So, what else can I say?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Take a look.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Jake: 没看明白
Jake: Didn't understand it.
Jake: 就是要要倒一下顺序
Jake: You just need to reverse the order.
Shure:  我交卷了老师
Shure: I'm submitting my paper, teacher.
Jake: 这样吧你们你们按照这个字母12123456
Jake: How about this, you all follow the letters 1, 2, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Jake: 然后按照字母顺一下
Jake: And then put them in order of the letters.
Jake: 不然我们这个就是像选择题答案一样
Jake: Otherwise, it's just like multiple-choice answers.
Jake: 知道吧我们一会对
Jake: You know, we'll check later.
Jake: 一会我们就会报这个
Jake: Later, we'll announce the answers.
Jake: EFCD之类的
Jake: Like EFCD or something.
Jake: 这种
Jake: Those.
Shure:  没问题
Shure: No problem.
Jake: 来写一下
Jake: Come on, write it down.
Alice:这导一下吗
Jake: 没没看明白就是
Jake: Didn't understand, so just...
Jake: 交卷
Jake: Submit it.
Alice: 就是一到六
Alice: Just from one to six.
Jake: 答题卡答题卡
Jake: Answer sheet, answer sheet.
Tasha: 44
Tasha: 44.
Alice: 23
Tasha: 1
Alice: 4
Alice: 5
Alice: 哎
Alice: 给
Jake: 给收卷
Jake: Collect the papers
Lucia: 纯净水的矿泉水
Lucia: Purified mineral water
Jake: 好收卷
Jake: Okay, collect the papers
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake: 收卷
Jake: Collect the papers
Lucia: 完了
Lucia: Done
Lucia: 卷子没写完
Lucia: Didn't finish the paper
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Oh
Katrina:  答题卡没涂
Katrina: Didn't fill in the answer sheet
Shure:  答题卡没涂
Shure: Didn't fill in the answer sheet
Alice: 答题卡没涂
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Oh
Jake: 不着急不着急
Jake: Don't worry, don't worry
Jake: 再品一品
Jake: Take your time
Jake: 说实话农夫山泉那杯我一定选对
Jake: Honestly, I definitely picked the right one for Nongfu Spring
Katrina:  这有啥区别
Katrina: What's the difference
Shure:  农夫山泉跟他们那个确实打的不一样
Shure: Nongfu Spring and theirs are indeed different
Shure:  农夫山泉明显不甜
Shure: Nongfu Spring is obviously not sweet
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Shure:  我还有一个同学
Shure: I have a friend
Shure:  只要一喝农夫山泉就会拉的
Shure: Who gets diarrhea whenever he drinks Nongfu Spring
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes
Katrina:  太那个什么经典说娃哈哈的公子
Katrina: That's classic, like the prince of Wahaha
Alice:收卷
Shure:  哈哈哈只能喝娃哈哈
Shure: Haha, only drinks Wahaha
Lucia: 不好意思三五
Lucia: Sorry, 35
Tasha: 我就只能喝我就尝出来了娃哈哈的味
Tasha: I can only drink and taste Wahaha's flavor
Lucia: 一个都尝不出来
Lucia: Can't taste any of them
Katrina:  我去真的
Katrina: Really?
Alice: 这个可以
Alice: This one's okay
Katrina:  这一般是便利店里有
Katrina: This is usually found in convenience stores
Katrina:  什么买哪个便宜卖哪个
Katrina: They sell whichever is cheaper
Lucia: 那个可以看看
Lucia: That one is worth a look
Jake: 答题卡是不是都没写名字呀
Jake: Did everyone forget to write their names on the answer sheets?
Jake: 谁是谁啊
Jake: Whose is whose?
Jake: 一会互相面面
Jake: We'll see in a bit
Jake: 大家都知道
Jake: Everyone will know
Jake: 大家都知道对
Jake: Everyone knows, right?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina:  今天我的生日
Katrina: Today is my birthday.
Shure:  批卷是吧
Shure: Grading papers, right?
Katrina:  要把这
Katrina: We need to...
Jake: 批卷准备
Jake: Prepare for grading.
Jake: 批卷
Jake: Grading papers.
Lucia: 这些其他能不能多选一个答案啊
Lucia: Can we choose multiple answers for these?
Lucia: 这样保证至少有对的
Lucia: That way, at least one would be right.
Jake: 可以啊可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 这个策略是可以的哈哈
Jake: This strategy is doable, haha.
Shure:  快递放在一楼椅子上了
Shure: The package is on the chair on the first floor.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure:  太有那个高中监考老师那味了
Shure: It's totally like a high school proctor.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 走来走去
Tasha: Walking back and forth.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Shure:  在晃悠
Shure: Pacing around.
Shure:  然后那个拖鞋还咔咔咔的声你知道吗
Shure: And those slippers making that "clack clack clack" sound, you know?
Tasha: 啪啪啪
Tasha: Tap, tap, tap.
Jake: 然后没事看一看你们的答案
Jake: Then casually checking your answers.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Katrina:  然后咂一声
Katrina: Then making a sound.
Katrina:  嗯然后这个同学就慌
Katrina: And that student gets nervous.
Shure:  然后在他旁边叹口气唉唉
Shure: Then sighing next to him, like "Sigh, sigh."
Alice: 唉
Alice: Sigh.
Jake: 再指指点点
Jake: Then pointing things out.
Jake: 这题写错了
Jake: "This answer is wrong."
Tasha: 点 就是不说话
Tasha: Just pointing without saying anything.
Jake: 帮2分呵呵
Jake: Giving 2 points, haha.
Alice: 也不当就这样
Alice: Not really, just like that.
Alice: 就指点一下
Alice: Just pointing it out.
Lucia: 然后就这样吧
Lucia: Then that's it.
Jake: 好的互相p吧
Jake: Alright, let's grade each other's papers.
Jake: 我们也不想看
Jake: We don't even want to look.
Shure:  互相p照
Shure: Grade each other's photos.
Shure:  我天
Shure: Oh my.
Katrina:  我天呐天呐天呐
Katrina: Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Shure:  真的是给外国人一些
Shure: Really giving something to foreigners.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  这是我自个的
Shure: This is mine.
Katrina:  这这不是我的吗
Katrina: Isn't this mine?
Jake: 这是
Jake: It is.
Lucia: 啊写了写了
Lucia: Ah, I wrote it down.
Shure:  那个我也写这个啊
Shure: I wrote this too.
Lucia: 这我自己认
Lucia: I recognize this.
Tasha: 这什么意思啊
Tasha: What does this mean?
Tasha: 看不懂
Tasha: I can't understand it.
Katrina:  老铁
Katrina: Buddy.
Katrina:  你自由我扯
Katrina: You're free, I'll pull.
Tasha: 三是a是吧
Tasha: Three is A, right?
Jake: 是谁的呀
Jake: Whose is it?
Jake: 真的是你的
Jake: Is it really yours?
Katrina:  是我的呀
Katrina: It's mine.
Tasha: 那他这个e写的是啥呀
Tasha: Then what does his E mean?
Lucia: 那是我的哦
Lucia: That's mine.
Tasha: 一是c好行
Tasha: One is C, okay.
Jake: 好好来
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Alice:好，公布答案
Alice: 公布答案
Alice: Announce the answers.
Jake: 公布答案
Jake: Announce the answers.
Jake: 一第一个是
Jake: Okay, the first one is...
Katrina:  我倒是写了
Katrina: I did write it down.
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Jake: 一个是啥呀
Jake: What was the first one?
Alice: 第一个是啥
Alice: What was the first one?
Jake: 第一个是a
Jake: The first one is A.
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 第一个是农夫山泉
Jake: The first one is Nongfu Spring.
Jake: 第二个是啥
Jake: What's the second one?
Jake: 第二个是苏打水d嗯
Jake: The second one is Soda Water, D, hmm.
Shure:  这倒是能尝出来嗯
Shure: You can taste that, hmm.
Jake: 第三个是百岁山
Jake: The third one is Baisui Mountain.
Katrina:  二是b第三是c
Katrina: Two is B, three is C.
Jake: c第四个是e
Jake: C, the fourth one is E.
Jake: 这个都这不能不对了
Jake: This one must be correct.
Jake: 第五个是娃哈哈
Jake: The fifth one is Wahaha.
Jake: 是b
Jake: It's B.
Shure:  你还给人家改
Shure: You even changed it for them.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina:  不小心就是
Katrina: Oops, it just happened
Lucia: 哎呀这手控制不住
Lucia: Oh no, I can't control my hands
Katrina:  ABC
Katrina: ABC
Jake: 我是不是
Jake: Am I
Jake: 我是不是写错了
Jake: Did I write it wrong?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice: 第六个是啥呀
Alice: What's the sixth one?
Katrina:  FS
Katrina: FS
Jake: 第六个是
Jake: The sixth one is
Jake: 第六个是娃哈哈
Jake: The sixth one is Wahaha
Lucia: 第六个是娃
Lucia: The sixth one is Wah
Jake: 没有第五个是怡宝
Jake: No, the fifth one is Yibao
Jake: 第五个是怡宝
Jake: The fifth one is Yibao
Jake: 给你们一些surprise
Jake: Giving you guys some surprises
Shure:  第五是怡宝
Shure: The fifth one is Yibao
Lucia: 所以第五个是F
Lucia: So the fifth one is F
Jake: 第五是一对
Jake: The fifth one is correct
Jake: 第五是f
Jake: The fifth one is F
Lucia: 第六个是b
Lucia: The sixth one is B
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 好吧我给人家写标上答案写错了
Lucia: Alright, I wrote the answers wrong
Katrina:  哎随便批吧
Katrina: Just grade it randomly
Shure:  你就只错了两个
Shure: You only got two wrong
Katrina:  真的吗纯瞎写
Katrina: Really? I just wrote randomly
Katrina:  2分钟写完
Katrina: Finished in 2 minutes
Shure:  农夫山泉和娃哈哈
Shure: Nongfu Spring and Wahaha
Shure:  顺序反了
Shure: Got the order reversed
Shure:  剩下都是对的
Shure: The rest are correct
Lucia: 这是
Lucia: This is
Jake: 几分啊
Jake: How many points?
Jake: 大家都几分啊
Jake: How many points did everyone get?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on
Tasha: 这是谁的
Tasha: Whose is this?
Shure:  这是我的
Shure: This is mine
Jake: 好这个是我们
Jake: Alright, this is ours
Jake: 从我们从宇轩的乌鸦的考卷开始是吧
Jake: Let's start from Yuxuan's crow exam paper, right?
Alice:我的
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey
Katrina:  3分
Katrina: 3 points
Lucia: 刚把这些都交回去了
Lucia: I just handed all these back.
Shure:  哇哈乌鸦3分
Shure: Wow, Raven got 3 points.
Katrina:  f b这是b是对的
Katrina: f b, this b is correct.
Katrina:  对不起批卷老师有点那个哦
Katrina: Sorry, the grading teacher is a bit...
Tasha: 4分天呐
Tasha: 4 points, oh my god.
Jake: 来大家看看有没有改错
Jake: Come on, everyone check if there are any mistakes.
Jake: 呵呵呵太典了
Jake: Haha, this is classic.
Katrina:  批卷老师批错了
Katrina: The grading teacher made a mistake.
Katrina:  然后去办公室找批卷老师要
Katrina: Then go to the office and ask the grading teacher for it.
Jake: 乌鸦得了4分
Jake: Raven got 4 points.
Katrina:  天呐
Katrina: Oh my god.
Jake: 修硕几分啊
Jake: Shure, how many points do you have?
Jake: 你也是4分
Jake: You also got 4 points.
Shure:  但是我把怡宝选对了
Shure: But I got the Yibao question right.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 你选几分
Jake: How many points did you get?
Katrina:  我也是4分
Katrina: I also got 4 points.
Jake: 都是4分
Jake: All 4 points.
Shure:  呀
Shure: Yeah.
Alice: 3
Alice: 3.
Shure:  最后一个交卷
Shure: The last one to hand in.
Shure:  和第一个交卷的人答案是得分
Shure: And the first one to hand in has the same score.
Shure:  这个得分一样
Shure: Their scores are the same.
Jake: 几分
Jake: How many points?
Katrina:  2分
Katrina: 2 points.
Jake: 2分
Jake: 2 points.
Alice:3
Jake: 你为什么得2分
Jake: Why did you get 2 points?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 好这是3分
Jake: Alright, this is 3 points.
Jake: 2分3分一排4分
Jake: 2 points, 3 points, a row of 4 points.
Jake: 那决胜一下
Jake: Let's have a tiebreaker.
Katrina:  好石头剪刀布
Katrina: Okay, rock-paper-scissors.
Katrina:  石头剪刀
Katrina: Rock-paper...
Tasha: 他们仨
Tasha: The three of them.
Shure:  他仨
Shure: The three of them.
Jake: 怎么决胜呢
Jake: How do we decide the winner?
Katrina:  石头剪刀布
Katrina: Rock-paper-scissors.
Jake: 你们你们喝出吧
Jake: You guys, you guys taste it.
Alice:石头剪刀布吧
Jake: 你们喝出来这这这
Jake: You guys taste this, this, this...
Jake: 3瓶矿泉4瓶矿泉水的味了吗
Jake: Did you taste the 3 bottles of mineral water, 4 bottles?
Lucia: 两瓶纯净水两个矿泉水
Lucia: Two bottles of purified water, two bottles of mineral water.
Lucia: 只能看别的
Lucia: We can only look at others.
Lucia: 大概
Lucia: Roughly.
Katrina:  这这位不是专业嘛
Katrina: Isn't this person an expert?
Katrina:  他说他
Katrina: He said he...
Shure:  我怡宝是能喝
Shure: I can drink Yibao.
Alice: 怡宝比较甜
Alice: Yibao is sweeter.
Shure:  对怡宝真的是这里面最甜的
Shure: Yes, Yibao is definitely the sweetest among these.
Alice: 然后农夫山泉有一点辣嗓子
Alice: And Nongfu Spring is a bit harsh on the throat.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice: 有点涩然后他没有味
Alice: It's a bit astringent and flavorless.
Alice: 然后他有一点点那种
Alice: And it has a bit of that...
Alice: 厚
Shure:  好像
Shure: Seems like...
Shure:  好像只有农夫山泉是偏碱性的
Shure: Seems like only Nongfu Spring is slightly alkaline.
Alice: 就农夫山泉不太好喝
Alice: Nongfu Spring doesn't taste good.
Shure:  我也觉得
Shure: I agree.
Katrina:  哦我喝出来了
Katrina: Oh, I tasted it.
Alice: 怡宝比较甜
Alice: Yibao is sweeter.
Jake: 好那这样吧我们
Jake: Okay, then how about this...
Jake: 我来看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Katrina:  哎不对不对不对
Katrina: Hey, no, no, no.
Katrina:  嗯农夫山泉是几啊
Katrina: Hmm, what number is Nongfu Spring?
Shure:  农夫山泉
Shure: Nongfu Spring...
Shure:  农夫山泉是一
Shure: Nongfu Spring is number one.
Jake: 好这样吧
Jake: Okay, how about this...
Jake: 我们来看一下各位手机的电量
Jake: Let's check everyone's phone battery.
Jake: 然后决定这个
Jake: Then decide the...
Jake: 最后的赢家
Jake: Final winner.
Tasha: 我已经失败了
Tasha: I already lost.
Shure:  我也是百分之18
Shure: Me too, 18 percent.
Katrina:  50
Katrina: 50.
Lucia: 96
Lucia: 96.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Jake: 哇
Jake: Wow.
Lucia: 昨天晚上刚充的电
Lucia: I charged it last night.
Lucia: 早上就拔下来
Lucia: Unplugged it this morning.
Jake: 恭喜96号玩家
Jake: Congrats, player 96.
Alice:擦不掉了
Katrina:  晚上也充了玩
Katrina: Charged it last night too.
Katrina:  玩到了50
Katrina: Now at 50.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Jake: 好的那我们就按照这样的顺序
Jake: Okay, then we'll follow this order.
Jake: 96
Jake: 96.
Alice: 96
Alice: 96.
Jake: 呃 96
Jake: Uh, 96.
Jake: 先选礼物对吧
Jake: Choose the gifts first, right?
Jake: 一会我们会把每个人的礼物给拿上来
Jake: Soon, we'll bring everyone's gifts up here.
Jake: 介绍介绍
Jake: Introduce them.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  嗯我们要自己拿一下是吗
Shure: Hmm, we have to bring them ourselves, right?
Jake: 对你们自己拿上来
Jake: Yes, you bring them up yourselves.
Jake: 然后我们把披萨也拿上来
Jake: Then we'll also bring up the pizza.
Jake: 你们就边吃边聊吧好吧
Jake: You can chat while eating, okay?
Jake: 然后这个水就当边吃披萨边喝就好了
Jake: And you can drink this water while eating the pizza.
Katrina:  好这是我的
Katrina: Okay, this is mine.
Jake: 这是你们的饮品
Jake: These are your drinks.
Katrina:  一天8杯水
Katrina: Eight glasses of water a day.
Lucia: 哈哈哈一天8杯水
Lucia: Hahaha, eight glasses of water a day.
Lucia: 这才6杯
Lucia: This is only six.
Lucia: 还差两杯
Lucia: Two more to go.
Jake: 大家把礼物拿上来吧
Jake: Everyone, bring your gifts up.
Jake: 好吧一天可是一杯也没喝呀
Jake: Okay, you haven't even had a single glass today.
Katrina:  今天可是一杯也没喝呀
Katrina: Yeah, not even one glass today.
Lucia: 我看看我给里面装东西了吧
Lucia: Let me see, did I put something inside?
Lucia: 别光带了个盒就搞笑了
Lucia: Don't just bring an empty box for laughs.
Shure:  没事客气了你
Shure: It's okay, no need to be so polite.
Alice: 给自己倒点怡宝
Shure:  我闻到有榴莲的披萨了
Shure: I smell durian pizza.
Jake: 我们把这个
Jake: Let's...
Tasha: 不是这个
Tasha: Not this one.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 没事不是
Tasha: It's okay, not this one.
Jake: 哪个
Jake: Which one?
Lucia: 这水把它掺一块
Lucia: Mix this water together.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: Then...
Tasha: 卖苏打水和元气森林
Tasha: Sell soda water and Genki Forest.
Lucia: 呃和元气森林已经喝完了
Lucia: Uh, and we already drank all the Genki Forest.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 这样我能节约点空间
Lucia: This way I can save some space.
Lucia: 给他两杯合一杯
Lucia: Combine his two cups into one.
Katrina:  磕
Katrina: Crack.
Jake: 对都喝吧都
Jake: Yeah, drink it all.
Jake: 然后这个披萨大家一起摆一摆
Jake: And then let's all arrange the pizza together.
Alice: 哎不得先交换吗
Alice: Hey, shouldn't we exchange first?
Alice: 先交换还是
Jake: 边吃边
Jake: Eat while...
Jake: 边吃边聊
Jake: Eat and chat.
Lucia: 本餐厅招募信息如下
Lucia: The recruitment information of this restaurant is as follows.
Jake: pizza Tuesday pizza first day
Jake: pizza Tuesday pizza first day.
Tasha: 榴莲的在这个箱子里
Tasha: The durian ones are in this box.
Tasha: 啊哎
Tasha: Ah hey.
Lucia: 怎么这么多啊
Lucia: Why are there so many?
Lucia: 还有小食是吗
Lucia: Are there snacks too?
Katrina:  鸡哥
Katrina: Brother Chicken.
Lucia: 这是小龙虾味
Lucia: This is crayfish flavor.
Katrina:  我好想吃小龙虾
Katrina: I really want to eat crayfish.
Lucia: 那可以把小龙虾摆的靠那边一点
Lucia: Then we can place the crayfish a bit over there.
Lucia: 我没看错吧
Lucia: Am I seeing this right?
Lucia: 上面写的好像是小龙虾
Lucia: It seems to say crayfish on it.
Tasha: 这个和这个一样
Tasha: This one and this one are the same.
Tasha: 放到这哎
Tasha: Put it here, hey.
Jake: 这个是一样的吗
Jake: Are these the same?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 照烧牛肉
Lucia: Teriyaki beef.
Lucia: 哦我以前很喜欢吃这个味
Lucia: Oh, I used to love this flavor.